- Today we're going to be giving fans
Stranger Things inspired looks
and I will be dressing
the characters today.
So the show is set in late 70s, early 80s,
midwestern America.
A lot of the clothes that
they wear are so wearable,
even in this day and age,
because vintage recycles itself.
And I think one of the most
remarkable things about
the characters on the show is how they all
seem to have their own
distinct, personal style.
Each character really has
their individual looks that
brings their personality to life.
So this isn't just your
typical recreation,
it's not meant to be costume-y.
It's supposed to be
really wearable like say
if Barb is a girl you're
hanging out with in Williamsburg
at a dive bar what would she
be wearing in the modern day?
So for Will there's that really
amazing opening scene where
he's seen riding his bike
disappearing into the Upside Down,
so one of the looks that
we wanted to do for him was
one with the puffer two-toned jacket
and then we have this plaid
flannel underneath and it
also has those red tones and
the chevron on the jacket;
so it's a nice color play
and I think it works well together.
- I'm a big fan of Stranger Things.
I do feel like a slightly
older version of Will.
Ya know, he liked The
Clash a lot and they were
pretty ritzy when it
came to their jackets,
so I think it's pretty sweet.
I actually related to Will a lot.
I was always pretty awkward.
in middle school, I was
kinda a smaller, scrawny kid.
People tended to pick
on me from time to time
and I also moved around a lot,
so I was more like lost
than I think most kids were.
My mom and I were kinda like
the only ones for a while.
She was a single mom for
most of my childhood life,
so I really related to him a lot on that.
- [Apneet] Eleven is a
central character in the show.
And one of her most iconic like looks
is that pink dress with the blue jacket.
It's a really important part
of the series just because
that's the first time she gets
to go out and go to school
with the kids and interact with everyone.
We gave her a corduroy jumper
paired with this really
cute navy bomber and some white sneakers.
And it's kinda like this
sporty, tom-boy vibe
and I really think it speaks
to her character because
she's really tough and she's
basically up for anything.
- This outfit is actually really cool.
This jacket is kinda oversized
which is really nice.
I'm pretty sure Eleven would
totally be rocking this outfit
right now if she were
walking down the streets.
Eleven is one of my favorite
characters on the show.
She is such a bad ass, does things without
even having to tap into her power;
she just does it out of the
necessity of making sure
her friends are okay
and I think that's the
coolest thing in the world.
- [Apneet] Dustin has kinda like
a quirkier personal style I think
than all the other characters.
He's always wearing those truckers hats
and his signature graphic tees.
We kinda did little twist on this.
Instead of his brown-colored
khakis we pair it with a skirt
and kind of turned it around
so that a girl or a woman can
also wear like a Dustin-inspired outfit.
We wanted to put her in a denim
jacket instead of his puffy
oversized coat just to
update it a little bit
and keep it modern.
- So I'm in the girl version of the look.
I think that it's dope.
Definitely something I could wear out.
I'm really digging this jean jacket.
I wanna keep it, I'm not kidding.
Best thing about Dustin is he's
like in it for the friends.
Like he's in it for the team
and I think that I'm also in
it for my friends and team.
So we have that kinda parallel
going where you just want to
make sure that like everybody's good
and like fighting for a good cause.
- [Apneet] For Lucas we
chose to recreate the look
where he's wearing
that bandana.
I feel like that's kind
of like his war paint
with such an iconic look for him.
He's always wearing these
great shearling jackets,
so I think that's kind
of his signature look.
And Lucas is gonna be wearing
skinny jeans today just
to update the look a little
bit to tie it all together.
- Lucas' fashion, I feel, is very smart
but also outdoorsy, it's back in style.
The character Lucas I
actually relate to the most.
I'm the friend that always
the voice of reason,
but still continues to go
with the band of friends,
but always in the back of my
mind I'm always questioning
why are we doing this and
what's going to be the end?
- [Apneet] For Barb, her
signature look is definitely
the oversized spectacles
paired with a plaid shirt
possibly has ruffles or
some kind of embellishment,
but in kind of like a quirky way.
We updated her look with a
floral blouse and some Levis
and a little fringe bag to give
it a little bit of an edge.
And I think that her overall
look is just very wearable
because it's really casual;
it's basically just
like jeans and a blouse
and you can just do so much with that.
- There's like the main
picture that everyone
has of her where it's like very
diaper-y in the pants area.
And this is like it
come down which is good
cause ya know, you don't want diapers.
I think I really like
Barb because she like
really didn't give a fuck
which was nice 'cuz it's not,
you see all of the people
following her around with
peer pressure and she's kinda
like I don't want to do that
and I'm just gonna do my own thing,
but then she got eaten by a
monster so that's unfortunate.
- I hope you guys like the looks.
It was really fun creating
all of these characters
and if you're inspired by this
video to go out and create
your own looks, dive
into your thrift store,
grab some friends, grab some lights,
and just make it a party.
(relaxed music)